hello everyone
and welcome back to the end game class
uh as always my name is caleb denby and
today
i'm going to be taking you through uh
the
endgame technique of ulf anderson of
course
we are going to be going through uh some
crushing games where elf despite having
even material and despite
having uh you know sometimes even just
objectively equal positions
is able to somehow some way defeat
his opponents through uh some some
crushing end game technique
so let's just jump right into it first
up i have a game of
ulfs against uh karl robach
robosh rabosh and i'm actually noticing
that this could be made slightly bigger
which i'm going to do now
bam all right looks good and let's just
jump into the game
so old vanderson starts with knight f3
knight f6 c4
c5 g3 b6 none of this matters why are we
looking at this is this an opening class
no this is an endgame class ah pieces
are being traded this is good
more peace trades more peace trades a6
and all of a sudden
look at that look at that move 15
and we're in an end game i love it i
love it
so uh old fingers in here has the white
pieces against as i said
carl uh last name whose last name is
hard for me to say with my mouth
robot robots tsch that's a tough one
so what do we think is is going on here
of course you know black's last move a6
might be considered a little bit dubious
the idea is of course you just keep this
knight
out of b5 and you allow your your pieces
sort of another alternate route into the
game right
uh for example if you play move like
knight d7 uh this is
perfectly fine for black as well but
carl chooses a6
in this case robot robotch robot
robot robot i'm never going to get
anyways
so what do we think is going on here uh
of course if anybody is to be preferred
it should be
white right white has this knight on d4
compared to this knight on b8
the rooks are connected whereas black
strokes are disconnected
but is it really going to be enough for
an advantage well
ulf anderson says yes he says absolutely
this is enough for an advantage is carl
german i don't know a ton about carl
robots
uh to be honest with you but we are
focusing on
off today just say robotnik that'll work
okay well i'll just say robot
anyways uh how do you press positions
like these
for an advantage uh with white
well obviously uh
the thing to do is number one try to
activate your own pieces
and number two try to make sure it's not
easy
for your opponent to get some activity
so how can you go about doing that well
uh off starts with this move right a to
c one which is of course sort of the
most natural move in the position
what's the point of rook c1 well the
point is it prevents natural development
knight d7 no longer playable because
rook c7 is going to invade
sort of with a devastating effect he put
this rook on c7
now all of a sudden black's pieces are
totally immobilized
and here what was at first glance sort
of a
very innocuous position is suddenly
turning into some very serious advantage
for white for example you could very
easily already lose
a pawn or more to stuff like 96
android takes d7 when this rook is just
going to be a monster
on the seventh rank rook b7 b5 or b6 for
example
and white is is close to winning so
knight d7 not playable you have to keep
this rook out of the seventh rank so you
see every move
uh ulf plays is with the idea of
activating his own pieces
or preventing his opponent from
from activating his pieces as well ah
yes and the chat is telling me
carl here is austrian good to know
okay so rook a7 and how does olf
continue well
you know we got this rook active we
might as well try to activate this guy
as well
and so he starts with the move rook c2
number one
guarding his own second rank number two
preparing to double up on the c file if
necessary
and then uh carl responds with rook d8
so how do you want to deal
with this idea of rook d8 what should
white play
in response what do you think
what can be done here
how should we respond to rook d8 and and
why so you guys have the right idea the
right idea is to just play e3
i think practically this is the best
move but why is e3 better than let's say
you know knight f3 for example
at least get his name right i mean i i
would if i could
the number of times i'm prepping these
lectures
and i get sidetracked for 20 minutes
trying to figure out how to pronounce
somebody's name
it's it's obscene i'm going to be honest
with you
if you think i'm getting carl's name
wrong just wait for the next game
alright you just wait for the next game
you just wait for game number two of
tonight
so yeah there are some good good points
here you know knight f3 sort of
undevelops our knight our knights good
on
on d4 but the the point i really want to
get across
is that if we can help it we want the c
file to effectively be the only open
file on the board we control the c file
right now
we want the c file to be the file that
matters
and with e3 we are trying to ensure that
the d
file stays closed that this file does
not
matter uh of course black does have an
option to sort of open this file by
force and we're going to see that a
little bit later in this game
in fact on the next move but this idea
still sort of stands
you want the only open file uh that
matters
to be the one that you're in control of
and so with e3
uh olf is trying to keep this d file
blocked
or in the case of e5 which is played
provoke his opponent into creating more
weaknesses
so after e5 it's true we do in fact have
to move this knight
but after the natural move knight f3 all
of a sudden now
things are happening with tempo right we
are attacking
this e5 pawn and we are provoking our
opponent to make even more weaknesses
in his position and so now black plays
the move
probably the best move f6 just defending
this pawn
on e5 now let's see if you guys can spot
wolf's next idea to continue pressing
this position
for an advantage by the way i want to
say
already white is significantly better
right it looks like black has done
nothing wrong
but white is very significantly better
already in this position
double up so yeah double up is a good
move i'm not going to lie rick fc1
great move but olf's idea is very very
instructive
very instructive
rook fc1 is great it's a great move not
going to get mad about anybody playing
work f to c1 here
but if you play rick fc1 then your next
move should be the move that olf plays
here and yeah it's not h4
it's not h4 h4 is not the idea h4
doesn't actually help white here
it's the move g4 and
g4 is the type of move that looks great
once you see it but can be sort of
difficult to come up with
on your own right it looks sort of a
natural to move upon from g3 to g4
but what's the idea the idea is
f6 is a weakness in black's camp how is
black ever gonna solve this weakness
well sometimes maybe he'll push to f5
and e4 right if we ever
for example end up on the sixth rank the
f pawn tries moving it's probably gonna
move to f5
and if we play a move like h4 for
example
uh obviously f5 here hangs this pawn uh
but let's say you know a couple moves
happen
and f5 and even on a really good day for
black let's say e4
uh these pawns are going to be difficult
to uh to sort of break down right once
black has achieved this super
uh super ultra awesome uh chain of pawns
it's gonna be a lot more difficult
to probe at those pawns to
make meaningful threats whereas if we
play g4 here
now if the move f5 ever comes on the
board
black white is going to be very happy to
capture this pawn when these
guys are starting to look very very
loose out here on the fifth rank of the
board now obviously these examples i'm
showing are a little bit you know silly
because that's not really how the game
is going to go immediately
but these are the sort of ideas you know
you play g4
to hamper your opponent's pawns to
prevent them from advancing forward
and sort of ice or sort of locking in
that weakness
on f6 so okay g4 is off's move here and
i think it's a really really good one
really instructive one of course you can
start with rook c1
but then you know after uh some move
then you should probably be following
this move up with g4 like you really
should be
playing g4 to try and lock in those
weaknesses
so g4 played first now uh rook d6
is played by black trying to take
control
over all of these important squares on
the seventh and sixth ranks
and off at this point does double his
rooks
uh carl's idea was to bring this guy out
to d7 and he does
exactly that and now once again
how do you play this advantage play this
position for an advantage
with white do you come to c7
do you come to c6 do you try to reroute
this knight somehow do you come to c8
even
what do you do
where do you go with your pieces here
uh g5 has been suggested as well
it's an interesting one
ariane says do not rush
no rushing for aryan
rook c7 has been suggested rook c6 rook
e2 is a bit of a strange one to me bit
of a strange one
so yeah i think g5 is a bit of a mistake
here i think g5 is a bit of a mistake
um i don't know if
f5 is actually the best move but e4 is
is playable
uh and if you go somewhere like knight
d4 well then you're sort of asking for
this
if you take on f6 first you're sort of
just activating your opponent's pieces
right something like knight f6
uh knight d4 for example and rook over
to f7
and all of a sudden black is fighting
back with with some counter play
so i like this pawn on g4 we are
keeping this pawn stuck on f6 we're not
encouraging it to move forward just yet
not encouraging it to move forward just
yet so rook c7 i also think is the wrong
idea
uh we've always been told you know put
the rooks on the seventh
and they are going to be very very
powerful but in this case
by going to the seventh rank you're
actually leaving yourself sort of on an
empty rank here right there's not too
much
going on on the seventh rank that's of
interest to white all of black's
uh weaknesses are on the sixth rank b6
f6 a6 they're all stuck on the sixth
rank and so the sixth rank is the rank
that white should be interested in and
that's why we see all play the move
rook c6 uh this idea of knight d2 by the
way
is pretty much just equally as good as
rook c6
but i do like starting with rook c6 for
the reason that the stand on f3 is
already
useful here uh pressuring this e5 pawn
we'll see in a second that wolf does
actually reroute this knight
but for the moment i like leaving it on
f3 in case black
does get any funny business ideas
playing for f5
can always go to h4 to pressure that guy
or
uh you know just pressure e5 as well so
i like the knight on f3 for the moment
which is why i think starting with c6
rook c6 is good black is more or less
forced to take this
if you try to step out of the way i
guess stepping out of the way would be
playable
but you leave white with this active
rook nonetheless and this rook
is sort of useless here for black i'm
not totally sure
what this guy is doing so we see carl
trade this guy off instead and then go
king f7 uh now
i would ask you how to make progress but
i sort of spoiled it off now
realizes that the other piece that needs
improvement is this knight here on f3
and so he steps to d2
we see king e7 and then he steps the
knight to e4
and we still have not won any material
with white we've played about 10 moves
in this end game so far
and believe it or not white's position
has gone from approximately
equal of course a small poll thanks to
his developmental advantage
to almost entirely winning uh just with
the peace play that olf has has managed
here he's
drawn his opponent forward into making
weaknesses and is now
exploiting those weaknesses and really
locking in
the black pieces this knight is a sad
entirely passive piece
this king also passively defending f6
and like what is this rook just
what is what is this rook what is it i
don't know what this is
but it's a bad piece that's what it is
rook b7
was played here by um
by carl which is i mean it's a good good
move as any uh he can't really move any
of his pieces
and now b4 is played by ulf
just taking a little bit of extra space
making sure this knight's ever jumping
out to c5
and now after rook b8 see if you can
find
uh ulf's winning idea this is where
things really start to collapse here
for black
this is where things you know very
visibly
start to fall apart 98 to 96
knight d6 to knight c8 i don't know i
don't know about that one in particular
that that does look like the funniest
idea but probably not the greatest idea
so what's a better square to check this
king from than c8 of course
as you guys are in the chat are saying
it's the d5 square knight c3 is the way
to go here
and knight d5 now is sort of unstoppable
uh with knight d5 sort of coming if
black were to pass somehow let's say
rook
b7 knight d5 king f7
it's true that black isn't losing any
material immediately
but at this point we're going to see
something sort of similar to what
happened
in the game where white can sort of just
slowly advance now with the king
moves like king f3 moves like king g3
and advance on the king side with the
pawns as well
ideas of h4 so rather than go for this
passive position
uh black instead tried this move f5
finally
with this knights you know leaving the
king side slash
center black felt the moment was right
to try to push with
f5 but now after knight d5 check
king f7 uh king g3
just defending this pawn uh we see the
move
h5 now by black again trying to sort of
break free
for some trades but g takes f5 and g
takes f5
and this is just entirely dead now
for black i i've said that before but
it's still true
rick d6 was the accurate choice by alf
drawing this rook back up to b7 where it
is you know passively defending you know
it could have gone to the king's side
from b8 but now it's very well stuck on
b7
and now uh white simply wins with king
h4
and this pawn is indefensible king g7 by
black king takes h5
and black had had enough in this
position and
white uh and he actually resigned here
and off
went on well i didn't go on to win well
he just won he just won here
you know all he did was sort of
slowly invade with his pieces and then
black just entirely crumb
crumbled under the pressure here and
there are
like somewhere in the realm of 80 games
by elf anderson that look almost exactly
like this one
some innocuous end game of starts
playing with his pieces
and then you know his opponents just
just fall apart this guy
was an absolute monster in the end game
so let's
let's recap here this is a 33 move game
all right
we have this end game appearing on move
uh 15.
black plays this slightly inaccurate
line i believe
but what do we have i mean we have here
in this position the pawn structure is
literally identical
okay it's it's literally identical right
the only difference in the position
is the placement of the knights that is
literally the only difference in the
position white's knight is here
black's knight is here and then after
the move a6 which i'm not gonna lie i
don't think is the best move i think
rook c8 is good
to you know contest this open file i
think something like an at7 something
like knight a6 should be considered
but a6 i mean it's not like a bad move
uh
rook ac1 is the start of the end right
you have to play your k7 now to keep
this rook out
and then rook c2 simply doubling rook d8
e3 now to defend this knight and i think
e5
is is really you know the first major
mistake by black and and ever since this
alf was in control and and never really
let go after e5
black has a weakness and that's all of
anderson needed
to to win this game knight f3 f6
and now after g4 black's kingside pawns
are frozen
and there's no way to comfortably
develop this rook is to the sixth rank
this knight is improved all the way to
d5
and just like that the game is over king
h
oh yeah sorry king h4
king takes h5 and black resigns that's
just it's obscene so any questions on
this game
before we move on to off anderson crush
number two
wolf anderson crush number two up next
all right let's go ahead and
switch back to the full camera view i'm
very
set up today very set up
and let's take a look at olf anderson up
against
dimitri boonsmon
boonsmon is how i'm choosing to
pronounce this name
alright please leave
in the comments below how to correctly
pronounce bonesman
boons man i don't know how do we know
the end game phase has
started uh it's a good question it's one
that i have
tried to tackle before on the show
basically it's it's open to
interpretation some people will tell you
the end game starts when the king is
you know no longer vulnerable to check
mating attacks
some people will tell you it's when this
number of pieces are left on the board
but you know there's always exceptions
to the rules of course in major peace
end games
uh there are positions that most people
would agree
is an end game but the king isn't really
totally safe yet
to play but it just depends you know
it's sort of a feeling
the end game is when you feel
okay so let's take a look we have
another
opening of some kind it's another
english by olf by the way and
more moves were played nobody really
cares why do we care about this
trade more pieces please trade more
pieces
oh my god please trade more pieces
there's still too many pieces
is there too many pieces when was i
going to start the end game here
yeah no there's too many pieces left no
okay
this i am calling a type of end game
it's more of a late
middle game but i'm going to call it an
end game because the play from here on
out
sort of just revolves around uh
around attacking weaknesses right and so
for my purposes i'm going to call it an
ending game i'm not going to lie to you
it's pretty early be calling this an end
game but you know what i don't care i'm
in charge here
i feel it's the end game right uh okay
so we just saw this trade bishop takes
e5 d takes e5 by alf
we see queen e7 and then off goes for
another
uh change of structure with e4 f takes
e4 and queen takes e4
okay getting rid of his doubled pawns
makes some sense
okay knight c6 is played now and i want
to ask your feeling on this position
chat room how do we feel
like uh how do we feel about this
this position do we like it for white
should black somehow be okay
what's the feeling here
chess king likes white
white is anderson first of all it's an
excellent point white is better
so why is why is white doing so well
here everybody tends to agree
but what what is it so yeah black has
a weak d7 pawn and that is of course
the major focus that that you should
first of all
notice there's also another real reason
why white should be better and that
reason in addition to the d7 weakness
is that he has all this king side space
right and space is usually of course a
middle game principle
and while you might argue with me say
that this is a middle game it can be
very very useful
in the end game as well as we'll see for
one of course
this spatial advantage in the center
keeps d7 as a weakness
but the spatial advantage on the king
side as well is going to be quite
relevant as we'll see
so in the game queen d3 was played by
ulf which is very natural to just
immediately attack this guy
rook f7 by dimitri to keep the pawn and
then we see off do a little bit of
shuffling he goes queen e3
you know talking to this rook on a7 so
rook a8 is chosen
and now rook d3 is very very natural
right he's just doubling his rooks
against the pawn on d7 rook f5
is dimitri's choice we see now knight c5
applies more pressure to this guy rook
d8 to defend
rook f to d1 and then the saddest move
of all time
is knight b8 and i feel like this is a
problem
that's uh everybody runs into
at some point during their chess career
where you know you should be better
right like white has to be better here
you feel like white should just be
winning
right this d7 pawn is so so
horribly weak that there's just
absolutely no way
black can be doing okay here right your
opponent just played the move knight b8
uh how on god's green earth is this
gonna be
surviving for black but then you realize
that if you play a move like queen d2
black plays rook f7
and you have to ask yourself well now
what
okay well sorry queen queen d2 is pretty
bad queen d2 is pretty bad right
um i guess now is the time to ask
yourself now what right you can't really
play queen d2 and hang a knight
uh and you you can't really increase the
pressure on d7 even if you
could rook f7 would defend this
would defend this guy again and so it's
like well now what you know
black has this weakness i attacked it as
many times as i
possibly could you know what's next for
white here
and that is where ulf starts to shine
in this game that's where his technique
is sort of
unbeatable by the way even though this
position
looks so horribly awful i will just
straight up tell you
that black is doing much much better
than he was
uh at after like uh
after the move g4 in the first game we
looked at
remember when white played g4 in the
first game and like black i mean black
looked uncomfortable
but not losing here black is doing much
much better
uh in this position than he was after g4
in the previous game
right so even though d7 looks so
optically ugly it's not that bad
not not that bad not just straight up
lost at least
so yeah olf's first step is to make sure
that his opponent doesn't have any type
of activity
this rook on b5 and he goes g4
rook f7 right which is fine
it's great knight b7 fork uh okay so
yeah what happens on
knight b7 this is a important question
one which definitely deserves an answer
which i am thinking of currently
yeah what's wrong with knight b7 you
guys make a good point here
what the heck i didn't even see this
move when i was analyzing
knight b7 huh
something must be wrong
yeah i don't know
i guess rook f8 if we take this guy
then uh then this guy hangs yeah this
makes sense
okay so g4 rook f7 i guess should always
be included to start with and now if you
play knight b7
obviously this is here so yeah the point
is knight b7 wasn't working
because of tactics so king g3 was played
in the game
and now rook df8 is played immediately
anyways so
knight b7 looked tempting but there was
always going to be a pawn hanging
in the previous positions uh which is
why
now after knight b7 of course there is
no threat
and rook takes f4 would be good so now
rook f1 and you might be thinking well
hang on a second let's let's rewind a
second let's rewind okay you can argue
that h5 is a little bit weak here but it
seems like
you know everything was under control
for white in this position and now all
of a sudden
after g4 we have a weakness on f4 a
weakness which our opponent is doubling
up on
so what the heck why did alf give
himself this weakness
on f4 what do you think guys why
why give himself a weakness like this
you know it was such a one-sided game
and now all of a sudden black is
seemingly getting some counter play on
our f-pawn
so what's the big idea here
chess king says he blundered fair enough
fair enough
did he have a choice so yeah you could
argue that because h5 was already weak
you sort of had to go for this but
not necessarily like a move like 94
would be playable here right if rick
takes h5
then you know this rook sort of gets
stuck on this side of the board
right tactically i'm not so sure this is
what black wants out of life
knight f6 check is coming this rook is
dying but
g4 was played and you could argue maybe
he just missed this but i would argue
that he played the g4 with a very
specific reason right
d7 wasn't weak i mean it's weak but one
weakness is not enough to win a chess
game so what olf does with g4
is he introduces new ideas into the
position on the king's side he's using
this spatial advantage
to give himself some ideas of either
pushing for f5 or pushing for g5 at a
later date in the game
and now black in addition to having to
worry about d7
is gonna have to worry about these ideas
on the king's side as
well uh black chose the move queen e8
here
uh which i mean is it it's a good of as
good of a move as
any for black it allows this knight some
freedom to move
by introducing this rook uh this works
defense to d7
rook f2 is sort of passing for a second
for white queen e7 is played rook d to
d2 is played and we see queen e2
you get this i'm going to level with you
isn't much more than shuffling for the
moment
rick d1 queen e8 rook t2 27
d1 28 and finally knight d3
uh so knight d3 of course relieves some
of the pressure on
this d7 pawn black chooses knight c6
now to bring this knight back into play
and now queen e4
by ulf centralizes the queen and puts it
on
a better square
queen b8 now by dimitri is an attempt
believe it or not to find some activity
this knight comes back to c5 now with a
threat
to the d7 pawn and rather than
just defend this guy uh dimitri actually
plays an interesting move queen
b6 so now what happens if
knight takes d7 everybody wants to know
well
turns out rook takes d7 rook takes d7
queen g1 is just going to be a simple
perpetual
no way out of this one for white
in fact no other legal moves or of
course you can go to h3 first
and it's a perpetual so this pawn not
capturable not
capturable so instead we see the move
queen e3 back
by olf now the knight comes back to b8
to deal with the threat to d7
see the knight come back to d3 offering
a trade of queens
black is fine with this queen on v6 so
we see more shuffling
and eventually we do see olf kind of
crack
and trade queens on b6 to keep the game
going
lost tempo well it's one of those
positions where black
wasn't really going to be doing anything
with the extra time so we saw both
players shuffling for a bit
until all cited on the best way forward
so we see c takes b6
right okay we got the rooks off the
board
now how do we continue in this position
well of course
we should reroute this knight to a
better square and olf does just that
with the move knight to f2 rook e to f
eight is natural now to keep the
pressure up
on f4 uh off brings this rook to d3
seemingly for not too much of a good
reason
it does sort of solidify the stroke on
f3 so
no it is for a good reason this was a
threat okay there you go that's the
reason had to defend the rook
rook a8 now is passing for black knight
e4 finally comes on the board
and all of a sudden the knight lands on
d6
rook after f8 is played and now knight
b5 is another good square
for this white knight uh rook to
rook f to d8 now to defend against d7
but now after rook d6 the pressure is
sort of mounting again
king f8 is played for black he needs a
second defender of the d7 pawn after
rook d3
so now king e7 and finally
uh white plays this move knight d4
trading off even more pieces
okay so knight takes or a takes b3 a
takes b3
and black sort of jumps at this
opportunity to get the knights off the
board right his knight wasn't doing too
much more
than shuffling between these two squares
rook b
a to b8 comes on the board and now
finally
it is white to move and get a winning
advantage here
right to move and get a winning
advantage
so there's actually only one move i
would argue
that uh that is winning here for whites
only one move
so yeah it's actually not so much going
to be g5 here
why isn't why isn't it going to be g5
well white
certainly isn't worse after g5 but black
can actually
find some activity here um
how can black find some activity well
with this move rook to
a8 now if we
take black and take we go something like
king g4
pretty natural rook a1 is going to give
us some activity
and if we go where it takes b6 by the
way still rook
a1 and the two rooks for black are going
to
sort of come careening into the game
right
and it's true that white might be
winning in this position as well i think
this works a bit better
for some checks uh obviously this is not
the ideal situation for white now is g5
the bad move uh
i'm going to say that probably white is
still winning but i think f5
is by far the the clearest way to win
this game
for uh
for white the reason being you get to
keep this g file closed and if
black tries the same with something like
rk8 first of all this stuff is still
going to be very very good
and secondly now if something like
rook a3 or rook a1 we have this extra
idea of f takes c6
and trading these guys off and taking
whichever pawn we won
and winning with two extra pawns very
clearly now i think g5 wins the games as
well i was sort of exaggerating when i
said only one move wins
but f5 is sort of the clearest in the
game black tried
b5 to keep this b-pawn on the board and
now after c5
wolf is still just dominating rook b to
c8
now c6 is the killer idea
and this is going to be an idea in many
many games
where you see one player sort of have a
crushing space
advantage because white's pawns are so
far advanced up the board
black is unable to take this pawn
because the king and pawn end game is
sort of hopeless
there's this tactic of f6 check
and this
will get the job done right
because white's pawns were so far
advanced these tactics just
do not work out for uh
for black so c6 is a winner rook c7 was
played in the game
and now the king and pawn again end game
once again
is going to be hopeless for black with
black essentially being
down upon of course technically the is
these are two pawns
but in a sense they really are just one
king f4 was played in the game
and black went ahead and resigned this
position if you go something
like king e7 i think
pretty much everything wins here king e4
for example
and if you start going this way keep a
lookout for f take c6 or even f6 here
tough tough tough tough right tough
tough tough
same ending with g5 wouldn't have worked
uh you might have a point there might
have a point there that might be why f5
is just so so much better
if b5 c5 here c6
yeah yeah and this stuff wouldn't
wouldn't work anymore
there's no f6 check so that's why f5 is
better it all
makes sense um
okay so questions
on this end game i feel like i was a
little bit less clear with my points
on this game the points i was trying to
get across
to review really quickly where yes black
has this weakness
on d7 but that is not enough to win a
chess end game
one weakness is not enough to end a
chess and to
to win a chess end game so
off instead pushes this move g4 and
keeps this idea of f5
sort of in his back pocket until the
moment is right for him
to play f5 and get this sort of winning
advantage right he uses the space on the
king side
to introduce more threats into the game
and eventually his opponent cracked
under the pressure
and that is why ulf wins
this game we saw of course
a lot of shuffling in this game and
liches
is killing me here a lot of shuffling in
this game
back and forth and eventually
we see black trying to activate this
queen but this queen trade
for white ends up allowing him to
improve this knight out to b6
and over to d6 and over to b5 and with
this trade of knights
rook b8 f5 and the game is over
yeah the queen trade did not really give
black relief it only allowed white to
activate this knight even further
and eventually trade off the important
defensive knight for
black all right let us do one more game
before we call it a day here i do have
one more for you guys
this one is going to be oaf against
michael francis steen uh and in this
game we have
yet again another english opening so
let's see how this one went
i'm just kidding nobody cares go fast
find the end game
fast ah queen takes d1 critical mistake
crit almost critical mistake for black
it's the best move in the position it's
the only move in the position
but never trade queens against old
anderson okay it's just a mistake
and we do see alf take on c6 as well to
slightly fracture the opponent's pawn
structure we see knight c3
e5 uh bishop e3 now
for alf uh trying to control the square
in front of the pawn
h5 h4 bishop b4 king d2
king e7 uh rook h to c1
and i'm sort of just playing through the
moves here i want one more trade of the
pieces we see bishop takes c3
rook takes c3 and bishop d5 so
what's going on in this end game
obviously
we know who won it was off
and we know that white should be better
because this pawn
on c6 is a bit backwards but
how good is it really how good is
it really
how good is it really do we think white
should be able to win this game
uh and if so how
should white be able to win this game
and how
so mark and or tracy says
opposite color bishops so it should be
holdable
okay bishop g5 by the way doesn't
doesn't win the game
there's just f6 and it's okay
paul says it seems drawing a few other
people say
white is better but they don't know if
it's winning
so yeah here's the problem for
white right uh it's sort of similar to
what we saw in the last game where black
has a weakness but it's it's
well defended right it's well defended
even more easily defended
than uh than in the previous position
so what's the issue for white
well the issue for white is yeah you
have this you know pleasant looking
position
but i don't know what white's plan
is right that's the issue uh
most of the end games i look at in this
endgame class are end games where either
there's a clear defensive plan for one
side or a clear attacking plan for the
other side and the problem is you know
finding that plan and making sure you're
playing that plan
and the thing that's incredible about a
lot of these off end games this these
old anderson end games is that
i there's no plan right you know it
seems like white doesn't have a plan
seems like black is just gonna you know
defensively sit there forever and ever
and ever
and then old anderson ends up winning
anyways and
uh i would be willing to call it you
know
a special type of plan where ulf is able
to just sort of
sit on these positions forever and ever
and ever and introduce these
like minuscule looking threats until
you know the moment when the opponent
just can't take it anymore and
and starts to crumble so the way to
start uh in this case is not with any no
funny checks uh moving this pawn to f6
is only an improvement for black's
position i think
but the way to start is to more firmly
lock down on all of these dark squares
so we see white play this move b4
and now uh black plays sort of any move
rook uh d to b8 was his choice really
doesn't matter for black
bishop d2 by white is olf's choice
we see a king e6 and then just to make
sure that nothing
really happens we see rook c5 by white
you know firmly locking down
this a5 break making sure that black
doesn't get any activity by the way
if white or black tried this move a5
here
he would in fact be losing a pawn thanks
to this tactic
that alfred set up with this bishop on
d2 so
if it was playable then black would have
loved to play a5 but i don't think it
was ever going to be
very good for example here it still
tactically loses
after rook b8 we saw this tactic with
bishop d2
and so after king e6 defending this pawn
it's now important for olf to make sure
that a5 can't be played
and that's actually pretty relevant
black would very very much love to open
the a file
and have some activity for his rooks but
he was unable to thanks to these tactics
that olfa anderson found rook b5 was
played now by
black trying to again get these ideas of
a5 to sort of go through alleviating
some of this pressure
and off just plays this move rook c to
c1 keeping pieces on the board
of course now with this bishop here no
longer being interfered with with the
rook on c3
uh white is very comfortably able to
stop a5
rook a to c1 while rook a to c1 would
potentially allow the opponent to trade
rooks i'm not saying black should trade
rooks
but you know if you want to sit on a
position forever you want to keep as
many pieces on as you can in most cases
so roxy to c1
is alf's choice f6 is a good improving
move now
for black and how should we continue
here
with white i'm curious to see what you
guys
think um the the good continuation is
here
for for white once again there are a
couple ideas to uh to consider
so yeah white isn't really interested in
doing things you know too crazy here
with stuff like g4
uh but yeah the the two main ideas in
the position are in the chat now so a4
is a great move for white you are just
claiming this one light square as your
own
but what effect this has is it sort of
makes the fifth rank entirely
uncontested
for white white is going to be very
happy to plant a rook on the fifth rank
and
always be pressuring e5 and indirectly
h5
uh sort of forever from the fifth rank
in addition stopping a5
also very very relevant so playing a4
is a good start to take over this fifth
rank with rook c5 to come
and then after rook g8 we see the other
idea being mentioned in the chat
f3 f3 is a great move here for white
is white trying to play the move e4
right away well
yes because it tactically wins but
deeper than that
of course black doesn't have to allow
the move e4
but it is provoking weaknesses along
this newly taken over
fifth rank right right black has this
option you can play e4 but this has the
effect of weakening h5 and in fact
losing upon immediately
uh or black can play this move f5 which
does of course weaken
all of these pawns along the fifth rank
now and
just like that a position where there
was only one weakness
for black on c6 has turned into a
position where black has
you know sort of four different pawns to
keep track of right white took over the
fifth rank
is now pressuring all of these guys as
well as the c6 pawn
and it's these sneaky little ideas that
olf uh
sort of uses that win him all of these
end games that are seemingly impossible
uh impossible to actually win
he finds these ways to create more
weaknesses for the opponent
and then things just start start to
crumble
so what should have been done instead of
this well perhaps
e4 would have been a prudent idea here
for
black stopping f3 before it ever
gets played instead though of course we
were treated to this idea of
f5 and now olf stays really really solid
plays king f2 before anything else
making sure these pawns are all well
defended
rook over d8 is uh michael's idea
and now uh olf plays this move bishop c3
and this move
actually comes with a threat so who
sees the threats i'm not going to pause
for too long here of course the threat
is to play
if black does nothing the threat is to
play e4
when after takes and takes this would be
a mistake due to rook
takes e5 with check so bishop c3
and this is what i mean by alf just sort
of poking and prodding
creating these tiny tiny little threats
against black's weaknesses
and just waiting for black to sort of
fall apart
so after bishop c3 really the best way
for black to respond to this is with the
move e4 which is played in the game
trying to get rid of this weak e pawn
and get all of the weaknesses at least
onto dark square or light squares where
they can be defended
by the bishop olf continues now with
rook d1
activating his final piece into the game
taking advantage of this pin
rook d to d7 is michael's choice to
break the pin on the bishop allow this
bishop to capture back on e4 if
necessary
and now king e3 activating the true
final piece for white
which is of course the king g6 now by
black to try and shore up these
weaknesses
and now a rather counter-intuitive move
by oath appears on the board
and it's a move which i think is just
wrong i i don't think
f4 really was the best way to play for a
win here i very much would have
preferred to see
ulf keep the option of king f4 and king
g5 alive
and just continue playing the position
right uh you can also try something like
uh f takes e4 trade one set of rooks and
then still have these ideas i'm invading
with the king
but f4 i think does lock down the
position in a way that favors black
so f4 played in the game but i don't
think this is one of those ideas that
you should sort of take to heart
i think this one was a mistake in my
opinion
but okay it's in the game let us
continue rook d6 played now and now we
do start a little bit of a shuffle fest
rook b1 7 bishop d4 king f7
b2 king e6 king d2 king f7 king c3 king
e6
rook a5 king f7 rook a6 rookie
seven and shuffle shuffle shuffle white
invades now with this bishop
rick eats d7 rook d2 rook b to c7
and basically basically what black is
saying okay you have two things to
attack i fixed my weaknesses on the king
side
and yeah you know go ahead attack them
i'm never moving any of my pieces of
pieces again
bishop e3 pass pass pass pass shuffle
shuffle
shuffle and finally off plays this move
e3
doesn't change the position too much
shuffle shuffle
um shuffle shuffle shuffle
shuffle and then
finally what is the idea
if black shuffles again off has
orchestrated his pieces
perfectly now for the knockout blow
and yeah rook c to a5 and all of a
sudden there is a third attacker on the
a5 pawn
and the game is over right three
attackers
is enough so what could black do
have done about this really not a whole
lot right
it was just basically very good play by
olf
and honestly he might have seen this
coming from
uh from here which is sort of obscene
right that's which is sort of ridiculous
i think black might have been able to
draw the game if you tried this idea of
a6
and the point now is after rook a5 uh
it's true you're attacking my guy
but bishop c4 is going to be a
sort of important defensive idea and
rook d5 to follow
is going to be forcing some
simplifications right
if you don't play rook a5 if you go
something like rook b1
or c1 for example king f7 for example
and retreat this along this file
all of a sudden rook b6 is going to be
the defensive idea
and basically no matter what you do
there's always going to be a way for
black to defend this a pawn
right rook 8 for example
and with the pawn on a6 it's very
difficult to add a second attacker
basically this is the issue for black
for white rather
but in the game we see this pawn stay on
a6 or stay on a7
and then alf just brings around this
third rook
over 30 different moves not quite that
many and the game
is over so rook b6 was chosen instead by
michael but now the rook comes over and
this pawn
well the spawn on a7 was going to fall
and after bishop a2
the pawn on c6 falls and the game is won
by white
okay so questions on this end game which
once again off anderson
just absolutely crushes his opponent
with his
unbeatable technique so questions on
this one
and then questions in general about this
type of endgame play
let me switch back now i think we are
about to wrap it up for the day then why
did he play bishop a2
well the position was just lost for
black bishop a2 was
uh i i honestly don't know why it was
played but black was sort of helpless
that rook takes a seven was coming
or bishop takes a7 rather white should
take with the bishop rather than the
rook
keeping rooks on the board is in general
important
in opposite clear bishop positions um
will i be on twitch so
yes directly after this clash this class
i will be going
live on twitch with analyze your games
so if you are watching live and want me
to analyze some of your games
rather than some of uh you know top
level grand masters games
then go ahead and go on and head over to
twitch
james says can someone really see 30
moves in advance well it's less about
seeing that many moves in advance and
more about realizing
there's nothing active that black can do
so black is essentially going to be
shuffling back and forth
and then trying to come up with the
perfect construction of pieces
for white and that's what alf was able
to do
link please uh i can type it why not why
not type it here
twitch.tv stl chess club
did that work maybe that didn't work
that did work all right so yeah that
is going to do it for us here today once
again
thank you so much for joining me and i
will see you guys
next time as i click over
here goodbye
you